Speaker 1: I want to play a video for you of
an attendee at a Turning Point USA event where
a woman blames Donald Trump for millions
of vaccine deaths. What? What, how? What
is she talking about? She says I'm a DeSantis gal
because Trump led to millions of vaccine deaths.
Listen to this. Trump or DeSantis, right.
Speaker 2: DeSantis All day. Why? Well,
because I don't like vaccine salesmen. And
millions of people are being killed all across
the world. And I blame Donald Trump for that.
Speaker 1: Right. Trump helped develop the
vaccines, she believes, anyway, and therefore,
Trump is responsible for the millions of
vaccine deaths around the world. You know,
I think at this point in January of 2023,
if you still believe the COVID vaccines
have killed millions of people,
I doubt I can say anything to bring you back to
reality. But this has been floating around for a
long time. There's just no evidence that people
are dying from the COVID vaccine. It's important
to understand that when these folks talk about
the VEIRS system, vaccine, adverse event reporting
system, VEIRS, anybody can submit anything they
want to the vapor system. It's not a definitive
source of information on vaccine safety. The
submissions to vapors include anything that
happens after vaccination, whether it's related
to the vaccine or not. You get a heart attack and
die ten months after getting vaccinated. It can
end up in vapors. And people like this woman will
say that's a vaccine death. There's is a passive
surveillance system. It relies on people like you
or me or a health care professional to voluntarily
report events that take place. It doesn't capture
all adverse events. It doesn't link adverse event
events to the vaccine. It doesn't do any of those
things. I even on a live stream, filled out
such a report, I didn't hit submit because
I don't want to be part of the fraud. But anybody
can just go in and say, got the vaccine and died.
It's not use useful in figuring out whether people
are dying from the vaccine. And when we ask the
question, do we have evidence that people are
dying from the COVID vaccine, the answer is no.
You have a combination of lies and then
just correlation that is not causation
in any way. Car accident nine months
after the vaccine shows up in vapors,
what is that representative of? The spirit
of what we're trying to track? It is not.
So unfortunately, this stuff is still around. It's
continuing to circulate. I don't know that I can
singlehandedly shut down the disinformation. But
the interesting thing with this particular woman
is DeSantis also said go and get vaccinated.
He later backed off and said, well, no mandates
and not these people. And that and consider that
the other thing. But DeSantis was also out there
saying people should get vaccinated. I don't think
I can change her. I don't think I can change any
of these people. But at some point, if we can,
it's good to introduce a little bit of reality
to some of these discussions. You may remember
that a few years ago the show got hacked and many
thousands of dollars were stolen. We never got
it back. It's a terrible feeling. It can happen
to anyone. But a couple of years ago, we got
Aura, which really gives us significantly more
peace of mind. And our sponsor Aura is the app
that protects you from scammers by alerting you
anytime your info like email passwords, social
security number are found in data breaches,
or also automatically requests removal of your
info from search engines and it can reduce spam
calls or alerts you quickly about suspicious
credit inquiries, like if someone tries to take
a loan out in your name and or is password manager
makes it easy to keep your account secure to begin
with. Aura also has parental controls for your
kids devices. You can restrict apps or manage
screen time, set focus time, make sure they're
doing homework instead of bingeing on YouTube.
You can try or a free for 14 days at aura dot
com slash Pacman. Use the free trial to see
if your email password are already out there.
You may be surprised the link is down below.